people these days are starving for
identity and community
people want to know who they are and and
what they are and why they are and
what's the point of everything so that's
why it seems like every day a new
community crops up a new community or a
sub community or an offshoot of a sub
community community of a community and
people will find their identity and
their community in anything at all it
seems like everything these days is a
community so it's a oh I I'm part of the
Blink community and very often people
will structure this around their sexual
there's their sex lives their sexual
proclivities so every sexual proclivity
becomes a community every fetish every
sexual interest is its own community and
it's an identity it's a lifestyle this
is my lifestyle this is this is the kind
of sex I like to have so it's my life
that's my identity it's Who I am as a
person and sometimes this craving for
identity you know it just kind of in our
culture it's getting increasingly
bizarre and just weird so there's so
many examples of just the weirdest kind
of identity people find for themselves
so of course one example just a classic
example now would be the bronies
bronies are adult adult men who enjoy my
little pony for some reason and they
dress up in my little pony costumes and
they go to my little pony conventions
and they wear my little pony apparel and
they creep me out generally and this is
their identity is that they like this
show for little girls and then there are
people who they they call themselves
super fans and their super fans of
something their super fans of a movie
like Star Wars or their super fans of a
show or a band or some other pop culture
thing and we call them super fans
because they have found their identity
in their fandom nothing wrong with being
a fan of something but then we go for a
lot what's happens very often is we go a
step further and people are obsessed
with this thing so you're like Star Wars
great then there are people that are
obsessed with Star Wars and this is
their life is Star Wars that this is
where they find their happiness and
their fulfillment they find themselves
in Star Wars so there's a new Star Wars
movie and they're camping out for three
days they forget about work free to our
family this is all that matters as Star
Wars and this again every you know it's
like seems like every film franchise
every kind of whatever it's whether it's
Marvel superheroes or whatever there are
these super fans these obsessed people
in the past I have I have myself run
afoul of the what is what is what the
kids call the beyhive and the beyhive I
never thought I would actually say the
phrase beyhive but I just did the
beyhive are their super fans of Beyonce
and so that gets what they call
themselves
and they just love Beyonce they
absolutely love and adore her and they
find their identity in her you know pop
singer
the point is we have a crisis of
identity in our cultural culture people
don't know who they are what they are
why they are literally they don't know
what they are because another thing is I
think they're I think it it's other kins
is another thing and that's other kins
are people who feel like they're really
animals inside so maybe they're really
maybe a person is an other kin because
she's really a cat inside so I shall
crawl around and shall wear cat little
cat yours and I don't know she'll use a
litter box I mean this is what I think
what happens in this quest for identity
people are are there rather than looking
without looking up
people are looking deeper and deeper and
deeper within themselves within their
own psyches within their own egos
they're just kind of plunging into the
depths of
of their minds of their subconscious and
they're just bringing to the surface
whatever they can find and what they
find deep down in there is really just
confusion and it's confusion that takes
increasingly dark and disturbing forms
but identity is what they want it's what
they need it's what everybody needs and
that's where Christianity ought to come
in
problem is that the christianity
professed from many pulpits is just
hollow and worldly and it doesn't give
people that meaning and that purpose and
that community and that identity that
they crave so let's just take for
example the Episcopal Church the
Episcopal Church this week announced
that they're going to be removing the
words man woman and procreation from
their marriage liturgy in just the
latest in their latest sort of bow to
the LGBT Lobby this is what they're
doing because it's offensive to the LGBT
people and Episcopalian Pisgah pelean
ISM has been kind of skidding into
oblivion for decades now over the course
of the 90s they lost over 30% of their
members and then in this century they've
been losing I think about 2% annually
every year and now there are fewer
Episcopalians in America now than there
are Jews which is significant because
the Jewish people have always been a
small minority in America the
Episcopalian Church on the other hand
the Episcopal Church hat used to be the
dominant church in America
not anymore what happened
well you can easily track
urges decline
over the past several decades and you
could track it because it corresponds
directly with the church shedding its
Christian orthodoxy in favor of liberal
secular worldly humanistic orthodoxy
so as there you just it's just the two
things are happening
attendance is plummeting as the as the
Episcopal Church are just getting rid of
one Christian doctrine after another
in the hopes each time of reversing this
decline and convincing people to come by
being less challenging and by being less
Christian but instead people just keep
leaving so it it began for the Episcopal
Church as always as it always begins it
began for them in the in the early to
mid 20th century when they embraced
birth control and divorce they got rid
of their prohibition of prohibitions
against birth control in the divorce
this is where everything always starts
okay and I know this is an uncomfortable
conversation because it's it's not only
Episcopal hsihu uh who embrace those two
things in our culture but here's the
thing our not just the Episcopal Church
but our cultural plunge into the abyss
began right there
with the proliferation of divorce and
birth control you want to find if you
want to pinpoint an exact moment that's
where it started that is where it has to
start
birth control and divorce
because right there that is how you
begin to undermine the family
and to and to destroy the entire purpose
of marriage and marriages the foundation
of the family so with divorce you have
forfeited the permanence of marriage
which is one of its defining
characteristics the other defining
characteristic of marriage is its is it
some procreative capacity so you thought
you forfeited the procreative capacity
of marriage you forfeited the permanence
of marriage and now you've marriage is
nothing now it serves no purpose it's
absolutely you've turned it into just
nothing
and so we did that decades ago decades
ago the Christian Church turned marriage
into nothing
and then we were shocked when eventually
the gays came and won gay marriage well
of course I could well be what we had no
argument to make against them
we've already said well yeah marriage
nothing that's not a sale permanent yeah
you can make a permanent vowel on the
altar before God that doesn't mean you
actually have to necessarily keep it and
yeah you don't necessary first
commandment of the of the Bible that he
gives the man and woman is be fruitful
and multiply it's a very first
commandment that God gives human beings
the very first thing he tells us to do
is to be fruitful multiply you don't
have to do that though you don't need to
that's not really the point of marriage
so the point of marriage isn't
necessarily to have kids it's not
necessarily a monogamous lifetime Union
then what is the point
and that's why we were so ineffective
when the gays came and they wanted
married and Christians were trying to
explain no I don't know you can't you
can't get married
and the gays said well why not well we
had no arguments to make coming from
this perspective what we've already said
marriage isn't necessarily permanent
appropriate procreative well then what's
our argument
um not to mention that when it comes to
divorce
this is one of the things
where Jesus I mean if you go and read
the Gospels
and you're reading them honestly it's
almost no matter how many times you've
read them
it's almost surprising how often Jesus
actually addresses this issue
it's Alma I don't know it's almost like
Jesus is God and he knew the situation
we were gonna be in it where that where
the world was gonna head I mean that's
almost what it's like right no that is
what Jesus is God and so he he's he's
speaking of course he was speaking to
the people around him he's also speaking
to us
and that's why this issue of divorce
comes up so often in Scripture and he's
so clear about
Jesus is so clear saying you cannot get
divorced getting remarried is a des
adultery it's what he says marry a
divorced woman it's adultery boom that's
what he says it's clear as day
so then they moved from there they moved
to the ordination of women
which again scripture so clear about
this st. Paul and the epistles could not
be more clear about who was supposed to
be leading churches men
Jesus couldn't have been more clear when
he selects 12 apostles and their own men
you could have selected women he had
plenty of women around him in play who
played very important roles
as we know women we're at the foot of
the cross women were the first to the
tomb on Easter morning so they played a
very important role they were not his
apostles though
you
that means something could've chosen
women he did he obviously wasn't
beholding to the bigotries of his time
as some people try to claim about Jesus
he was not a man of his time he was a
man he was a man transcending time and
and so but he only chose men and then
st. Paul comes in and confirms that no
men are the leaders in the church but we
said okay we're gonna ordain women and
then it was a straight line to the
ordination of openly gay clergy and then
the approval of same-sex marriage and
now there's nothing surprising really
about seeing a feminist Episcopal
preached blessing an abortion clinic or
a transgender Episcopal priest
performing a you know doing a service in
a church adorned with rainbow flags
nothing surprising about that and it's
even less surprising to look around
during that service and see that there's
nobody sitting in the pews because why
would they come and sit in the pews
there's no point what would be the point
right now what would be the point of
going to an Episcopal Church what why
why even go the message of liberal
Christianity whether it's the Episcopal
variety or any other variety the message
of liberal Christianity is you're
perfectly fine exactly as you as you are
everything you're doing is fine make no
changes keep up the great work
that's the message hey it's all good
exactly what you're doing right now just
keep doing that okay just yep thumbs up
that's the message now a very weak
person may be happy to hear that message
but they don't need to hear it twice
they don't need to come keep coming back
to hear it over and over again all you
need to do is hear it once and then
they'll just go off and and and live
their life they only need to receive
that affirmation one time and then
they'll just continue living exactly as
they were before just as lost just as
confused just as hopeless
the Episcopal Church like any worldly
Church
given everything it has to offer
you go to an Episcopal service one time
and sit down and listen to whatever
nonsense they're spewing that's it
that's all they got they got nothing
else to offer you
if a per person wants whirling
worldliness okay if what a person deeply
craves is worldliness
they can go literally anywhere else to
get it
that's the problem and if they want
lectures on diversity and inclusion they
can go talk to their human resources
director at work if they want
encouragement to just continue along in
their sin Satan is happy to provide it
using a whole host of methods in our
culture and most of those methods
whether it's through pop music or TV or
whatever will be far more entertaining
and enjoyable than anything that the
crusty old Episcopal Church can provide
so there's no point
if you want if somebody actually wants
what the Episcopal Church or liberal
Christianity will give them well they
can get it anywhere they can get it get
it anywhere in the world
so going to an Episcopal Church for
for the sort of Christianity that
Episcopal churches preach it's like it
would be like going to a fine dining
restaurant and ordering a Twinkie
it's just there's no reason if you want
a Twinkie you just go to 7-eleven you
can get it the Winkie anywhere
no if somebody sets to themselves I want
to go to a to a really good restaurant
then most of the time they want to go
because they're looking for something
substantial they're hungry they want
something real okay give me give me some
real food
and
and in the same way if a person
something higher okay if they want to be
rescued from the dreariness of modern
culture if they if if they if they want
to find their real and transcendent
identity
if they want to be challenged if they
want meaning
if they want purpose
if they want a mission in life well then
they have even less reason to go to
Episcopal Church or any other similar
variety of Christianity because it's not
substantial enough it's not different
enough it's not saying enough it's not
real enough it's not asking enough of
them see this is the great secret of
humanity that progressive inclusive
Christian leaders don't understand the
great secret is this religions grow
they expect more of their adherence not
less
expect more
be more orthodox
have a message that's more at odds with
the culture that's more demanding that's
more challenging that's harder
those are the religions that grow those
are the churches that grow
religions thrive when they provide a
lifestyle that is radically different
from the doll hollow pointless lifestyle
that the world provides because people
turn to religion for identity and if all
they find is more the same more of what
caused them to go looking in the first
place then they're not going to be
converted
Church wants to grow and more
importantly if it wants to save souls it
has to have the boldness to completely
entirely reject the teachings of the
world so just act like they don't exist
that's the way it should it should
operate that's the way Christian shop
should operate that's the way a pastor
priest should operate
that's the way churches should operate
the teachings of the world the opinions
of the world the orthodoxies of the
world don't matter it it's wrong it
doesn't matter it has no bearing
whatsoever on anything we do
and we do not care if how we live and
what we believe is diametrically opposed
to the world in fact if anything we
we find some encouragement in that
because we know how lost the world is
and if we were to ever look and see that
we're actually lining up with the world
on something that would be a bad sign
people are looking for a higher identity
they're looking for an identity that
transcends the world
and
you know this is it's it's a it's a
natural human desire
because everybody has this innate
recognition everyone has this innate
recognition
that
there's got to be more out there there's
got to be more to the world there's got
to be more to reality there's got to be
more to themselves
everyone everyone looks at themselves
and they want to change everyone wants
to change themselves that's the other
part of this so you look around our
culture and it's just people are it you
know not only they're finding their
identity in different places but they're
radically changing and and and doing
these makeovers
to try to change themselves and
sometimes in the most radical ways no
I'm gonna take it well I'm gonna change
my gender I'm gonna get surgery and
change my gender but even if they're not
going that radical it's still whether
it's extreme diet plans or it's this or
that or self-help books or motivational
seminars or whatever it is we're joining
a cult or something people are looking
to change they're dissatisfied with who
they are
they look at themselves they don't like
who they are they want to change they
want to believe that it's possible to
change they want to believe that it's
possible to to emerge into some other
kind of new identity that's that's
that's different from what they have now
because they're dissatisfied with it
and that's where the church has to step
in and says here's your new identity
here it is
you
and the longer that a person languishes
in the world
the longer they languish in sin the more
their identity kind of starts to fade
and the lines start to blur and they
become less that's what that's what sin
does to you it lessens you it makes you
less of yourself
that's why
um
I think I made this point before but
when you look at really evil people
when you look at
serial killers or school shooters or
serial rapists or whoever you know when
you look at the most deranged kind of
people who are just wallowing in the
darkest darkest sin when you look at
that there and then they're all kind of
the same aren't they it's like they're
interchangeable one with the other you
almost lose track of them school
shooters so which which one did which
one you know you can't even remember
they're all you know they all seem to be
identical in terms of just their
motivations the kind of people they are
just everything even their history their
family situation to be kind of just the
same they just blur together into one
just mass of into one weird gross
horrible fog of humanity that's what
they become
whereas when you look at the heroes when
you look at had virtuous godly people
well they're also distinct and different
and beautiful and their stories are
different and everything is just
different they stand out there like
these bright shining stars in the in the
midst of the [ __ ] they stand out they
are so distinct
because it's in that where we find our
selves and ultimately when we stand
before the throne of judgment we stand
before God we're either gonna be
welcomed home into communion with God
where we will finally find our truest
our perfected identity which is free
from all of these sorts of patches of
nothingness that are within us this kind
of sin these holes you know sin sin are
these these holes in our soul that are
there and and so we all have these bits
of emptiness in us some have more than
others
when we go to heaven well that's all
filled in that's all gone right or if
we're cast into damnation
then there we will go and we will be
just nothingness
which isn't to say that hell is real or
that we disappear and so we don't really
go down not saying that hell is real
souls go to hell Satan is real all
that's real but the souls in hell
have been stripped or rather they've
forfeited all that's real about them all
that's substantial
because everything substantial
everything beautiful everything distinct
everything real comes from God not none
of that goes into hell it can't
and so the souls in hell are just this
blur of ego
still there in in in in some way you
know now they're outside of time and
space but
so still existing
but
just nothing
I'm reading a book called the Lord by or
I just finished it actually it's called
the the Lord by Romano goir Dini it's a
beautiful book I highly recommend it
about the life of Christ
and he has a great line about judgment
he says that as you stand there before
God
you'll find out how much of you is
and that was a great way of putting it
kind of a terrifying putting it how much
of you still is
because there's the you that God gave
you and intended for you
and then there's kind of the anti you
but you claim for yourself through sin
that which does not come from God
Oh
so
Christianity should put us on the path
towards finding our true selves in God
but if it doesn't it
the church doesn't step up to the plate
then there are plenty of other places
you know that then people will find that
identity somewhere else why do you think
Islam is the fastest growing religion in
the world
because it is why is that I think about
it in our
in
progressive enlightened age Islam is the
fastest growing religion
why I mean this is a question the
Christians should confront and confront
it honestly
I'll tell you why because it expects
more of its adherents
provides a way of life that is
drastically different from the average
it expects it demands total submission
to its precepts
if you're gonna become Muslim you can't
partially find your identity in Islam
it's no there's no partial commitment
you're all in
praying five times a day everything
total reverence total submission
Islam is not afraid to talk about
obedience not afraid to talk about
punishment
concepts that have gone out of vogue in
western Christianity Islam is an
identity and so people come to it and
they find this whole new identity and
this challenge to live differently which
is what they want say what you want
about that identity but the fact is it
is one
which is more than I can say about
Episcopalian ISM
Islam is an identity being a biscuit
ball at this point is just nothing it's
just being nothing it means nothing
you
I don't have to go to his loan for
examples there are some churches in
America who have figured this out some
during a minority I gave a talk at a
church in Wisconsin just a few weeks ago
and it was a very traditional church
very Orthodox very conservative very
it was beautiful I loved it
and you know what else it was it was a
young church it was growing
I talked to the priest afterwards and he
told me that when he first came to the
parish
age for parishioners was 70
and then he got in and he got you know
he got rid of all the liberal reforms
all that you know all the fluffy stuff
you kind of started turning the clock
back by about a thousand years in terms
of how the the liturgies is is
celebrated and now
the average age of a parishioner is 35
why because it gives young people that
totally submersed radical Orthodox
experience that they crave
it gives there's a point there's a
reason to go to that church it had
there's a point to it
it stands apart from the world it's
completely different from what the world
is doing it does not echo or mirror the
world at all that's why so there's a
reason for it to exist
there's something else people crave they
crave virtue
virtue
we crave virtue so much but we find so
few examples of it in the culture then
now we turn to superheroes
in fact I was talking to somebody
recently and I you know and I've been
in the past I've made it clear that I
don't I I don't totally understand this
superhero obsession especially among
adults I get it it's fun but just you
know adults going to see every new
superhero movie and just so invested in
superheroes I don't get it I really
don't it's something about it seems well
I just don't get it
and I was talking to somebody about it
and they told me that they said well you
know it's it's an example of virtue it's
an example of you know these are good
guys and and so much of of Hollywood
these days is is all about anti heroes
and it's about these kind of tortured
people that are just kind of morally
ambiguous think of think of all the
quitting tarantia every Quentin
Tarantino movie ever made or just
everybody is bad in the movie there's no
virtue there's no goodness nothing
and he made the point that Walt with a
superhero movie say what else say
whatever else you want about it but at
least there are good guys and there are
bad guys and there's a moral distinction
between the two and they're fighting for
good things so that's why people like it
and
and I think that's a good point
but it's kind of sad isn't it that
people are so starving for examples of
virtue and stories of virtue and sort of
a defense of virtue so starving for that
they got to turn to Spider Man
they got to turn to Batman for it
when they should be able to turn to the
church
should represent that virtue should
defend the virtue and challenge its
adherence to live by virtue and defend
it themselves
challenged its adherents to be warriors
it'll be real warriors to go out and
fight
and it shouldn't be be afraid to say
that
that we are in a we are in a holy war we
are
may not it may not be a physical war
right now anyway but
we're in a holy war we're in a word a
war against the powers of evil
and there are a lot of them and there's
it's kind of overwhelming right now
and so the church should be saying go
out there and fight
there should be some of that militant it
should be kind of a militant
flavor
Christianity especially in our in our
damaged
that's how you build a church
the Episcopal model is how you destroy
it so
I guess we just have to decide which to
follow all right have a great weekend
everybody Godspeed